Transcriptor: Sylvia Vildosola
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hola soy Carolina y quiero hablarles
de lo que ocurrió en mi vida
cuando comenzó Facebook.
Abrí una cuenta
y empecé a recibir personas.
Las solicitudes que me hacían
las aceptaba.
En ese momento no pensé, por ejemplo,
que la gente pudiera tener
perfiles falsos.
Un día empecé a ver que uno de mis nuevos
amigos daba Like a algunas de mis fotos.
Lo que me llamaba la atención de esos Like
era que no se encontraban precisamente
en las fotografías en las que yo me veía,
desde mi punto de vista, más hermosa
sino que a veces estaba sin maquillaje,
o estaba un poco excedida de peso
y, sin embargo, les daba Like.
Así que un día me pregunté
que por qué él haría eso.
Decidí entrar en su perfil y me di cuenta
de que él, al que vamos a llamar señor T,
no tenía muchas publicaciones y pensé
que era un hombre extraño y reservado.
Pero, siendo mujer, siendo psicóloga
y en caso de que el horóscopo funcione,
siendo sagitariana, pensé
que desde la época de Noé,
sabes, las jirafas andan con las jirafas,
las cebras andan con las cebras
así que dije si él no publica
yo voy a saber quién es él
al ver a sus amigos
y entré a revisar a sus amigos.
Su primera amiga, casualmente,
era una mujer con discapacidad.
Dije, Ah, qué bien, él debe de ser doctor
o trabajar en el área de rehabilitación.
Pasé al segundo amigo,
una mujer con discapacidad.
Tercer amigo, mujer con discapacidad.
Y así fueron, una tras otra,
mujeres con diversas discapacidades
y cuando había llegado como a la quinta
ya sabía que él no podía ser médico
ni podía trabajar en el área de
rehabilitación porque, de ser así,
dónde estaban las fotos
de los estetoscopios
o del área de rehabilitación
o de sus compañeros, de sus colegas.
¿Por qué todas las que estaban allí
eran mujeres con discapacidad?
Y empecé a pasar del asombro al miedo
y recordé a mi esposo que me decía
que tenía que tener cuidado de no andar
metiendo locos en mi Facebook
y luego lo otro que
me empezó a dar fue ira.
O sea, ¿quién se creía para coleccionar
mujeres con discapacidad?
Y ese mismo día después de que terminé
de ver las 59 mujeres que tenía allí
y que tenían discapacidad
le escribí algo así como
La cosificación es un proceso en el cual
uno olvida a la persona
y la empieza a escoger por
características que la convierten en cosa.
Cuando buscas a las personas
porque son rubias,
porque son altas, o porque tienen
una característica particular
tú la estás cosificando.
Así que le dije que yo no le daba
el permiso para que me cosificara,
que yo no quería ser parte de su colección
de su casita de terror.
Él al día siguiente me contestó
que realmente eso que tenía allí
no era una colección de terror,
que todas las mujeres que estaban allí
le parecían hermosas,
eran objeto de su admiración
y que parecía que la que
tenía el problema era yo.
Luego de muchas conversaciones
con el señor T, un día él dijo:
¿Lo que tú quieres decir
es que yo soy un devoto?
Y yo no tenía ni la menor idea,
pero si él estaba diciendo eso
obviamente era devoto y le dije sí,
eso es exactamente
lo que yo quiero decir.
Cuando terminamos de hablar
yo fui a papá Google
y coloqué: "devoto" y aparecía
de la Virgen del Carmen,
del santo Niño de la Cuchilla
y de otros santos
y yo dije esto no es
lo que él me está diciendo.
Entonces, dado que habíamos estado
conversando sobre la discapacidad
coloqué "devoto" y "discapacidad"
y coloqué en mi Facebook,
donde había muchos psicólogos,
psiquiatras, estudiantes
de psicología, escribí:
¿Alguien sabe de una parafilia
que se llame devoto?
Y empezaron a bromear
y me dijeron debe ser alguien
que es fanático religioso y que a lo mejor
le gusta hacer el amor en contextos
que tienen que ver con la iglesia.
Y me di cuenta de que nadie
sabía acerca de eso
y entonces después de estar asustada
decidí investigar sobre eso.
De los resultados de esta investigación
y de sus implicaciones
es lo que les vengo a hablar hoy.
Por favor.
Un devotee es una persona cuya parafilia
se caracteriza porque experimenta placer
y porque erotiza a una persona
con discapacidad.
Por favor, la siguiente.
La palabra parafilia está formada por dos
términos filia que significa deseo, amor,
atracción y para que significa extraño
anormal patológico de manera tal que
parafilia sería algo así como
un deseo raro o un amor patológico.
Los "devotees" son personas
a los que les interesa,
a los que les erotiza, la discapacidad;
cualquier tipo de discapacidad.
Pero el tipo de devotees que yo estudio
son los devotees que están interesados
en personas como yo
con discapacidad motriz.
Así que esos devotees
se dividen en dos categorías:
los abasiofílicos que son aquellos
a los que les interesan personas como yo
que usan aparatos,
muletas, sillas de ruedas,
y los acrotomofílicos
a quienes les interesa
las chicas amputadas.
Desafortunadamente para mí,
los acrotomofílicos son mayoría.
Esta investigación o la investigación
que llevé a cabo a lo largo de 10 años
me permitió entrevistar a 2234 devotees
de cinco continentes.
Los entrevisté de manera personal
a algunos de ellos
y a otros a través de Internet
con entrevistas en español y en inglés.
Los resultados muy a grosso modo
fueron los siguientes:
el número mayoritario
de las personas devotas
tienen edades que están
entre los 31 y los 40 años.
¿Por qué? Yo hipotetizo,
o sea mi hipótesis,
es que después de los 40 años
algunas personas empiezan a tener temor
de acceder a la tecnología
y como la mayor parte de la muestra
la obtuve a través de Internet
por eso después de 40
el número empieza a descender.
¿Por qué menos de 30?
Porque la construcción de la
personalidad, el definir quién eres tú,
se va haciendo, sobre todo,
cuando tienes cierta madurez
y eso ocurre alrededor de los 30 años.
La mayor parte de ellos eran
masculinos, de sexo masculino,
tanto que la proporción es aproximadamente
de una mujer cada 250 hombres,
y ellos son de nivel socioeconómico medio
y creo que eso es lo que facilitaba
que tuvieran acceso a la tecnología.
Surgen varias hipótesis
acerca de qué es lo que hace
que una persona sea devoto
y en casi todos ellos he encontrado
que ha habido experiencia
con la discapacidad
bien sea de manera directa
porque ha tenido discapacidad
o de manera indirecta
porque han tenido algún familiar
o algún vecino con discapacidad.
Sin embargo, no todo el mundo que
ha tenido experiencia con discapacidad
se convierte en devoto
y entonces seguramente
al igual que cualquier fenómeno
psicológico, es de naturaleza multicausal
e incluye componentes biológicos,
psicológicos y sociales.
Lo que sí he encontrado es que,
con mucha frecuencia,
provienen de familias rígidas,
frías o sobreprotectoras,
que algunos de ellos
tienen baja autoestima
y que parecen tener necesidad de control.
Si eso es lo que he logrado como
resultado de la investigación,
y mucho más, pero que no me va
a dar chance de decirlo ahora,
¿qué temas quedan pendientes
por explorar?
Queda pendiente por explorar
por qué algunas discapacidades son
preferidas con respecto a otras, es decir,
¿por qué hay mayor cantidad de devotos
a los que les interesa
la discapacidad motriz con relación
por ejemplo a la invidencia?
Otro elemento importante es
¿por qué se da esa desproporción
entre mujeres devotas y hombres devotos?
Adicionalmente a eso ¿hay diferencia
en el perfil psicológico
entre los hombres devotos
y las mujeres devotas?
Y por último les comentaba antes
que parece haber un elemento importante
con relación a la experiencia
con la discapacidad.
¿Significa eso que en a aquellos países
donde ha habido guerras
o donde han existido catástrofes
y como resultado de ello
han quedado muchas
mujeres con discapacidad,
¿en esos países
hay mayor cantidad de devotos?
Adelante, por favor.
Venezuela, la actualización necesaria.
¿Por qué un tema tan rebuscado
podría ser importante
desde el punto de vista social
y qué tiene que ver con la actualización?
Yo creo que esto tiene que ver
con varios elementos.
El primero de ellos está en el hecho
de que se está haciendo
una investigación novedosa
con un gran número de sujetos
y esto del número de sujetos, por haber
tenido la muestra de 2234 sujetos,
te permite generalizar más fácilmente
los resultados conseguidos en esa muestra
a toda la población de devotos,
pero adicionalmente yo creo que
y lo más importante de esta
investigación es que ha permitido,
me ha permitido y ha permitido a aquellos
que están vinculados a la investigación
replantearse conceptos como
discapacidad, normalidad y belleza.
¿Por qué cuando se habla del tema
de devotos nos escandalizamos tanto?
¿Por qué percibimos que el devoto
es un depredador sexual?
¿Por qué pensamos que el devoto es alguien
que tiene una patología psicológica?
Los pocos, las pocas investigaciones
que hay hasta el momento en que lo vi,
solamente seis investigaciones
tres de naturaleza grupal
y tres de estudio de casos
y en todos ellos se abordaba
el tema de la patología, pero
¿Por qué nos parece patológico el devoto?
Y por eso coloqué una frase
de un devoto que dice:
Si estás con una, refiriéndose
a una mujer con discapacidad,
si estás con una eres un santo
porque la soportas,
pero si tú "quieres" estar con una
entonces te conviertes en un pervertido.
Siguiente, por favor.
Y probablemente lo que hace que veamos
al devoto como patológico es lo siguiente.
Es la forma en que nosotros
entendemos la discapacidad.
Entendemos la discapacidad,
o a una persona con discapacidad,
como una persona que no es productiva
o que puede ser una carga para el Estado
a la que tienes que darle una subvención,
una persona que no es hermosa
o una persona que tiene esa condición
como resultado de algún castigo divino.
Entonces si una discapacidad te hace eso,
te hace una persona disminuida,
cualquiera que pueda desear y erotizar
a una persona con discapacidad
definitivamente tiene que estar mal
y esto es algo importante
por lo siguiente:
yo no sé si Uds. se han enterado
que si viven lo suficiente
todos Uds. se van a convertir
en una persona con discapacidad
porque en la medida
que va pasando el tiempo,
la agudeza visual y auditiva
va disminuyendo,
vamos sintiendo dolores,
y entonces, si se viven lo suficiente,
Uds. también van a tener una discapacidad,
pero ¿cómo es el tema de
la discapacidad y la sexualidad?
Solemos pensar que las personas
con discapacidad son asexuales.
Y ¿por qué pensamos que son asexuales?
Porque generalmente la forma
en que comunicamos los deseos,
sexuales obviamente,
es a través de nuestros movimientos.
Porque coqueteamos con nuestros
movimientos, meneamos la cadera,
o caminamos de una manera particular
para manifestar que tenemos deseo sexual,
pero en una persona con discapacidad
el movimiento está alterado
y entonces no puede comunicar
de manera suficiente ese deseo sexual.
Eso se ve alterado.
Lo otro es que pensamos que
una persona con discapacidad
además de que no tiene deseo sexual
es como un niño;
un niño dependiente, alguien
que necesita que lo ayuden
y que por lo tanto lo tutelen.
Si es así, si la mujer es como un niño,
y si la mujer, la mujer
con discapacidad obviamente,
si la mujer con discapacidad es un niño
y además no tiene deseo sexual
entonces un devoto sería
algo equivalente a un pedófilo.
Esta lógica se siguió con Helen Stoll
que fue la primera mujer con discapacidad
que apareció en una portada de Playboy.
Retocaron sus piernas
para que se vieran normales
y no se vieran como las mías que
son más delgadas o más flácidas
y quitaron de las fotos
la silla de ruedas.
Y cuando le preguntaron a Hefner
por qué había tomado la decisión
de presentar a Stoll visualmente
como una mujer normal,
obviamente normal
en los términos de Playboy,
él dijo que de esta manera
impedía que Playboy caminara
por un camino de cosas
pervertidas y explotadoras
en los cuales se vinculaba la sexualidad
con las personas con discapacidad.
Entonces, la primera actualización
es preguntarnos
si realmente el que exista un devoto
está vinculado a un deseo pervertido
o es que somos prejuiciosos
con relación a la discapacidad
y eso nos hace ver como enfermos
a aquellos que puedan erotizar
a una mujer con discapacidad.
Lo otro que quisiera que
nos preguntáramos es
¿Qué es normal y qué es anormal?
¿Por qué consideramos que
los devotos son anormales?
Y ¿desde qué criterios son anormales?
Resulta que investigando
me he dado cuenta
de que el concepto de normalidad
puede ser visto desde distintas ópticas.
Desde el punto de vista legal
lo normal es lo que no es delito.
Desde el punto de vista estadístico
lo normal es lo frecuente, lo común.
Desde el punto de vista filogenético
lo normal es lo que hace
la especie humana,
pero que también hacen los animales.
Desde el punto de vista psicológico,
lo normal es lo que no causa daño.
Y desde el punto de vista moral
lo normal es lo que es bueno.
Entonces, por favor,
de ser así ¿qué es lo normal o desde que
criterio estamos hablando de normalidad?
Esa es la gran pregunta.
Lo otro sobre lo que quiero hablarles
es sobre el tema de la Belleza.
Nosotros tenemos el concepto
o el ideal griego de la belleza.
Y según ese ideal obviamente las mujeres
con discapacidad no son hermosas.
Pero existen otros ideales de belleza.
Uno de esos ideales de belleza
alternativos son el ideal japonés.
Utilizaremos la palabra,
espero pronunciarla bien,
se llama "wabi sabi".
Wabi sabi es el equivalente al ideal
de belleza griego pero en Japón.
Para que algo sea bello,
desde esta óptica,
debe cumplir tres características:
Nada dura, nada está completo
y nada está perfecto.
Entonces creo que en este momento
yo me siento mucho más cómoda
con el concepto de belleza japonés
que no me exige simetría
y no me exige perfección
que con el ideal de belleza griego.
Por último y esto es lo que
quisiera dejarles para la reflexión.
Si podemos cuestionar el concepto
de belleza en Venezuela
que es el país de las mujeres bellas,
si podemos construir, enriquecer,
ese concepto de belleza,
entonces en este país podemos
lograr cualquier cosa.
Eso es lo que tenía que decirles.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)